tras un segundo balotaje y con 67 votos
el congreso de perú eligió a jose
williams como su nuevo presidente luego
de un escándalo de audios que motivó la
censura de ley de camiones de la
jefatura del parlamento williams es un
general retirado dirigió a las tropas
peruanas durante el conflicto con
ecuador en 1995 y fue uno de los
estrategas de la operación chavín de
huántar en 1997 en la que se rescataron
72 rehenes de la residencia japonesa en
lima quienes estuvieron secuestrados por
el movimiento revolucionario tupac amaru
por sus acciones distinguidas en el
ejército fue designado en 2006 como jefe
del comando conjunto de las fuerzas
armadas eloy político de 70 años
dirigirá al parlamento de ese país hasta
el 28 de julio de 2023 tenemos la
responsabilidad de mejorar la imagen del
congreso afirmó williams y señaló que
mantendrá una relación de diálogo con el
gobierno del presidente pedro casi o
para satisfacer las necesidades de la
población el nuevo jefe del poder
legislativo también indicó que su
gestión respetará la división de poderes
y defenderá la institucionalidad del
congreso precisamente algunos analistas
sostienen que williams brindar el
contrapeso político de las relaciones
entre el congreso y el poder ejecutivo y
en esa línea señalan que williams podría
convertirse en el próximo presidente de
los peruanos si es que el parlamento
consigue remover el cargo al presidente
pedro casi o mediante un proceso de
vacancia presidencial por lo pronto
congresistas de oposición alista en una
tercera moción de impeachment contra el
mandatario peruano anuncian que en unos
días socializarán el borrador para
conseguir los 87 votos que se necesitan